in July 2017 mallanna vine troupe was
cast as Marvel superhero Squirrel Girl
in the new freeform comedy series new
warriors and while you might not
recognize the actresses name her face
should be familiar from TV roles to
webseries plus a certain gig with AT&T
here are all the places you previously
seen future Squirrel Girl mallanna vine
troupe a start on television vine trouve
landed her first memorable TV role as a
child playing an hiv-positive russian
girl named Tatiana on the classic
Hospital drama ER in 1995 Kara played by
future Good Wife star julianna margulies
wanted to adopt the girl but it didn't
work out and vine troupe left the show
after three episodes from there she went
on to small roles in Days of Our Lives
and Lizzie McGuire
but once the internet came into play
things got more interesting how do you
like how do you like them how do you
like them apples
an online star millena vine troupes most
famous work online came as the co-star
of the internet series let's talk about
something more interesting along with
fellow actress Stevie Nelson the 2011
series featured vine troupe conducting
intentionally terrible interviews with
celebrities like Matt Damon this was
also when vine troops started appearing
in college humor projects including the
Jake and Amir series as well as a famous
public service announcement about [ __ ]
resting face that might just be her
[ __ ] face
that's okay AT&T in 2013 mallanna fine
troupe score the role that would define
her career for years to come
Lily the friendly and patient Wireless
store clerk in a popular series of
commercials for AT&T Lily's a little
awkward little sarcastic and
occasionally flirtatious she's more
girl-next-door than spokesmodel like
someone you might actually encounter
working in an AT&T store well lucky as
Lily vine troupe has shared scenes with
regular Wireless customers as well as
celebrities including Gordon Ramsay and
james van der beek
and her natural charisma was surely the
key to the campaign's long run
you shouldn't go she ate more stuff
you're pretty good at it
key and Peele in a role is different
from her perky AT&T persona as possible
vine troupe made a mostly silent but
highly memorable appearance on the 2013
Halloween episode of Comedy Central's
sketch series key and Peele she's nearly
unrecognizable as the gorgeous vampire
girl hanging on the arm of Jordan peels
gothic Lord of the undead who gets
called out by a new member of the
vampire gang for making mealtime weird
I'm just saying y'all were here licking
and and hissing and whatnot if we don't
eat then let's eat damn although if you
stick around to see the vampires get a
makeover at the end of the sketch vine
troupe looks a little bit more like
herself House of Lies in 2014 vine
troupe appeared in the Showtime series
House of Lies in which he plays Christie
a consulting firm employee who's both
fired and arrested after stabbing your
boss Monica Talbot played by Dawn
Olivieri
although she only appears in two
episodes her memorable performance
showcased yet another very different
kind of character from the one she
played in those AT&T ads Silicon Valley
you also might have spotted vine troupe
on HBO's Silicon Valley her character
Terra's the girlfriend of Martin Starr's
cynical Bertram guilfoyle and like
Bertram Terra's a practicing laveyan
satanism I go sputters director Paul
Feig this 2015 series was part of the
launch of Yahoo's streaming service
Yahoo screen vine troupe starred as Tina
shuck skip a flighty and unpredictable
starship navigator
unfortunately Yahoo scream failed to
generate profits for the struggling
company and the whole thing was shut
down in early 2016
that's the spirit
love vine troupe also had a crucial if
short-lived role in the first two
episodes of love the Netflix original
series
she plays Natalie whose messy breakup
with Gus played by Paul rust sets the
events of the story in motion that lead
him to a happier healthier relationship
can't do nothing before she was an
actress mallanna vine troupe was
actually a refugee having fled the USSR
with her parents in the 1980s in the
United States the Soviet Union is
finally allowing thousands of Jews to
emigrate and leave their lives of
religious persecution with her status as
a celebrity vine troupe found herself in
a position to help other refugees around
the world in 2016 she founded can't do
nothing a charity dedicated to helping
displaced people from Syria and
elsewhere amid a turbulent presidential
election in which the refugee crisis was
an ongoing issue it made news that the
AT&T girl was involved on a personal
level
this is us Milana vine tree was most
visible role today it's her eighth
episode arc on the massively successful
NBC drama this is us
she played Sloane Sandberg a playwright
and romantic interest for Justin
Hartley's Kevin Pearson sadly because
the show is essentially a soap opera
their relationship ended in dramatic
fashion as did Vine troops work on the
show sorry anything to do
but high-profile guest roles like this
one lead to bigger things and it's not
surprising to see mallanna vine troupe
move on to new warriors sure right now
it feels like she'll always be Lily from
those AT&T commercials but soon Squirrel
Girl might be the reason why everyone
knows vine troupes name thanks for
watching click the looper icon to
subscribe to our YouTube channel let's
check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love to
[Music]